what are the categories of small things
small biological things in this world
that can kill you
kill us humans
let's let's look you said like most
viruses are friendly or at least not
unfriendly right but let's look at the
unfriendly ones and viruses and bacteria
and those kinds of things when you look
at the full spectrum of things that can
kill you
can you kind of paint a brief picture
yeah i think
the big picture is that
the things that can kill your minority
of everything that's out there and we're
talking about
molecules so we have in us
proteins that can kill us yeah prions
that are just
it's a protein in us and if it misfolds
it makes all of its other
copies misfold and then you you die of a
neurological disease yeah that's pretty
rare
um so there are proteins there are
viruses
and as i said only certain ones
can kill us
but even though if we get those from
animals it's not straightforward if you
look at sarsko v2 right this is probably
a once in a hundred year pandemic i
would say equivalent to 1918
in its devastation and in between there
have been smaller pandemics of other
other viruses but it doesn't happen all
that often so we have a lot of viruses
we have a lot of bacteria
of various sorts that can cause
infections in us
and there's this it's a limited number
right your streptococci and
staphylococci and clostridium we could
go on and on but
we know how to handle those as long as
we have antimicrobials it's just that we
abuse them and we get resistance so that
can be a problem then we have fungi
not mushrooms but much smaller fungi
that
multiply submicroscopic or just at the
microscopic level they can
you know in dry climates of the us you
can inhale their spores and they can
grow in your lung if you're
immunosuppressed and so forth so those
are
the tiny guys and then we have parasites
which we we do this week in parasitism
where
single cells even worms of various sorts
can invade you and cause all sorts of
problems
how um i was like kind of terrified to
listen to that podcast what uh what's it
like
i mean
what you learn is that
you can you travel somewhere and you can
get infected and bring it back home yes
here in the us we do have
certain kinds of parasites but
because of our lifestyle we more or less
have avoided them for example there is a
parasite called toxoplasma
which
has is infected most of the world
actually because a lot of people like to
eat raw meat and you would get it from
from raw meat and we're not as fond of
that here in the u.s
uh we like to cook our meat but that
could be a consequence of
eating raw meat is that what leads to
what is it called taxoplasmosis
yeah so toxoplasmosis um
it's mainly
a big issue is if you're pregnant and
you get toxo then your fetus is going to
be
very badly malformed it's going to have
brain defects and so forth
um
and animals can get it as well
so there are a lot of parasites of that
nature which you often acquire by food
eating food of different sorts and it
usually happens elsewhere we just on
this week in parasitism we do
a case so daniel griffin is a resident
physician he's a doctor a real doctor
right and he every month he comes up
with a case okay this is a person i saw
and last month this young lady had
traveled somewhere and
she ate
raw fish
she was just somewhere southeast asia or
something and she ended up with
with with red bumps all over her skin it
turned out it was a parasite from the
fish that moved around in her and and
they're very easy to cure
we have if the right doctors and the
right drugs you can cure all these what
about diagnose like connect the red
spots to the fact that it's a parasite
it's very easy to if you have the right
diagnostics now daniel often goes to
parts of the world where they don't have
diagnostics and he has to
use other mechanisms he may have to take
a bit and look at it under a microscope
and then he may not be able to get the
drug depending on where he is
but if these but often he sees patients
who come back to the u.s and they get
diarrhea or they have a fever and he
said where have you been and he can put
two and two together and so we let our
listeners do that and they all send in
guesses and it's wonderful to hear them
go through this so there are a lot of
parasites puzzle and solvent
you have to be careful about eating when
you go overseas and water too water as
well and you know in parts of africa
there are parasites in the lakes and if
you go swimming they can
invade you and in fact it can go into
your hair follicles and burrow in and
get into your bloodstream that's
exciting so um daniel is interesting
because he's very adventurous he doesn't
he's not afraid of any of this
so there's a famous lake in africa lake
malawi
where which harbors a lot of these
parasites and he said oh yeah yeah i
just make sure i towel off vigorously
when i get out
and get ignorance get rid of them and
that was the name of an an episode but
you know food
vigorously you know sushi you can uh you
can get worms from sushi yeah and the
solution is to freeze it
and many sushi restaurants now have
liquid nitrogen they snap freeze their
sushi and that kills all the parasites
and a study was actually done
in japan showing that freezing does not
alter the taste of sushi because
except you see a big industry yeah
that's brilliant
you